the giver is directed by Philip Noyes
and stars Jeff Bridges Brendon Thwaites
and Meryl Streep and this film is based
off a very popular book that basically
everyone in my elementary school read
when I was in elementary school and you
know it's a book so it's a movie now
that's what they do look kids like
equals movie that's just what happens
now this film tells the tale of a
futuristic world in which a small
community of people live in a place
where there is no evil in fact they
don't even see in color anymore everyone
sees in black and white and there is
only one man who remembers how things
used to be has those memories within him
he's been enlisted to give his memories
to young Brendon Thwaites as the one
person that they feel is capable of
withholding these memories of how things
used to be now Jeff Bridges is
apparently been wanting to make this
movie for 18 years he originally
approached the author of the book 18
years ago with his father Lloyd Bridges
in mind for the role of the giver and I
walked into this movie thinking that it
looked really bad I mean the trailers
did not do the film any justice and the
film is a little bit better than I
thought it was going to be actually in
fact there are large portions of this
movie that actually had me interested in
the characters and what was going on
unfortunately though there are equally
large portions where I really wasn't
interested in the film really had a very
dull vibe which makes sense because for
the first act of this movie virtually
every character except for Jeff Bridges
is just a lead balloon that sinks to the
bottom of the ocean they have no emotion
there's nothing interesting about any of
the characters except for him
but in the scenes where young Jonas
visits the giver and they learn about
the past the movie really did pick up a
bit and it actually had some very
beautiful themes woven throughout it
although a lot of them are very
heavy-handed in regards to biblical
messages apples and trees and a search
for knowledge where you're trying to
figure out what sin is and learn about
evil and things like that definitely a
lot of Adam and Eve and Garden of Eden
parallels to be found in this movie some
of it really does hit you over the head
pretty hard though and it wasn't too
subtle
I think Brendon Thwaites is a really
interesting young talent with quite a
bit of stuff to offer in this movie he
was very good in oculus and I think that
he was very good in this movie too and
I'm interested in seeing where else he
goes throughout his career Jeff Bridges
was fantastic in this movie and you
really could tell that he had a lot of
heart
and soul invested in this role his
character by far was the most
interesting out of all of them he was
the only character in the film where you
were able to look at him and imagine a
past life and in my opinion that's the
best type of character in a movie is
where you can actually imagine this
guy's lived beyond the runtime of this
movie he existed before this movie
started and those are the best type of
movie characters characters that feel
lived in as if they actually are real
people and Jeff Bridges character in
this film the giver was by far the best
aspect of this movie Philip Noyes is a
good director and I've liked a lot of
his films in the past like clear and
present danger or patriot games and he
makes a very nice-looking movie here
although a lot of it does feel
excessively dull like I said but it's
hard to make a movie really interesting
when every character in the film is
aggressively uninteresting it's not
until later in the movie where at least
one or two characters in this movie
actually start to understand some things
and progress beyond the very dull
characters they started out as but up
until then I was kind of bored by the
whole thing and then the movie did start
getting better the movie has a nice
visual look to it Brenton Thwaites and
Jeff Bridges are very good in the film
meryl streep I have a lot of respect for
her but didn't really add much to this
movie which is kind of shocking to say
because she's such a good actress the
giver gets a C+ it is better than I
thought it was going to be but the
performances aren't really that great
because the characters are so dull and
boring as people then it takes so long
for them to get interesting as people if
you're a fan of the book I wouldn't say
that it demeans it I just would say
maybe check it out on blu-ray guys thank
you so much as always for watching if
you've seen the film or you love the
book let me know what you think about it
below as always guys thanks a lot and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck myn eyes
Oh